salut alors des vidéos sur la
rationalité il y en a un paquet sur
youtube pourquoi en faire une de plus et
bien parce que je trouve que la
présentation qu'on en fait
habituellement passe à côté de tout un
tas de problèmes
je ne veux pas dire qu'il faut la jeter
à la poubelle juste qu'elle passe à côté
de certains problèmes qui me semble
important
je voudrais donc tenté de représenter
une version aussi complète que possible
tout du moins autant que le permet le
cadre de ces vidéos pour éviter que ce
soit trop long et trop indigeste
j'ai décidé de segmenter jusqu'à
récemment quand je commençais mon cours
sur la rationalité j'essayais de faire
passer à mes étudiants
le message selon lequel est rationnel
c'est un mode d'existence trop cool je
pense bien sûr je suis sincère mais je
veux représenter un peu trop le truc
comme une alternative à leur mode de vie
actuel je leur disais en somme
devenu rationnel vous allez voir c'est
trop bien j'ai mis du temps à percuter
qu'il ne fallait pas présenter les
choses ainsi
pourquoi oui les gens pédagogique et
bien d'abord parce que comme on disait
dans la vidéo de présentation
les maladies liées à l'irrationalité en
général sont très souvent invisibles
pour la personne atteinte
on est malade sans en avoir conscience
donc on ne voit pas à quel point on est
malade
à quel point on a besoin d'un traitement
et puis j'ai insisté sur le fait que
nous sommes tous malades que nous sommes
tous concernés par le problème
ce qui me semblait présenter une raison
supplémentaire de s'intéresser à la
situation avait l'effet inverse si c'est
vrai tout le monde après tout pourquoi
s'embêter à essayer de corriger ces
erreurs
il aurait fallu insister là dessus notre
vie dépend de facteurs dont on n'a pas
confiance et ces facteurs déterminent
notre capacité à imaginer notre vie
différemment
pour le dire autrement comme un des
effets indésirables de la maladie
consistait à nous empêcher de voir que
l'on est malade à nous empêcher
d'imaginer à quoi ressemblerait une vie
en bonne santé on est incapable de
percevoir la gravité de notre état c'est
pourquoi ma règle d'or c'est nos
croyances détermine nos actions et nos
actions des conséquences pour le monde
mais on pourrait aussi dire l'idée que
je me fais de la réalité défini
l'expérience que je fais de ma propre
personne est définie mon comportement
avec les autres
d'où l'importance d'interroger nos
croyances et nos conceptions du monde
l'autre erreur pédagogique c'est que ça
peut laisser entendre que mes étudiants
ne sont pas du tout rationnel ça fait du
mode d'existence rationnelle quelque
chose de lointain de pleinement
différents or ce n'est évidemment pas le
cas personne n'est 0% rationnelle tout
le monde prétend à une forme de
rationalité tout le monde justice
puis ses pensées ses sentiments c'est
normal la question ce n'est pas figé
rationnelle mais plutôt comme un sujet
rationnelle donc il n'y a pas d'un côté
les esprits irrationnels et de l'autre
les esprits rationnels comme on dit dans
la vidéo sur la discussion on imagine
parfois dans la sphère sceptiques que le
problème c'est d'être biaisé non non
nous sommes tous biaiser le mal du
siècle ce n'est pas que l'on soit
biaisée le mal du siècle c'est qu'on
ignore le vrai danger c'est l'excès de
confiance et cela menace tout le monde
j'ai envie de dire surtout ceux qui
pensent être plus rationnelle que les
autres il ya plein de façons différentes
de décrire l'attitude rationnelle une
que j'aime bien consiste à dire est
rationnel c'est faire du mieux qu'on
peut avec ce qu'on a
je vais essayer de montrer ce que peut
vouloir dire cette phrase mais d'abord
avançons pas à pas notre expérience de
la vie est guidée par des intuitions
forte
je veux dire par là qu'il ya les
impressions qui s'impose dans notre
existence
il faut prendre en compte ses
impressions par exemple nous avons
l'impression très forte d'exister comme
individu dans un monde
on a l'impression que notre vie est une
espèce de face à face entre soi et la
réalité
ensuite on peut dire qu'on a
l'impression forte d'être libre on fait
une expérience de la vie qui donne le
sentiment de pouvoir prendre librement
des décisions de faire des choix
on a aussi un peu l'impression d'être
double un corps et un esprit on a
l'impression d'avoir accès à la réalité
en somme que ce face à face dont on
parlait et grosso modo transparent je
suis dans le réel
est ce que je perçois est la réalité
cette réalité on dirait donc à nous est
donné elle est là devant nous et
indépendante de nous ça veut dire
qu'elle est comme je la vois même quand
je ne suis pas là pour la regarder
c'est une impression forte que la
réalité existe sans moi enfin on
pourrait dire aussi qu'on a l'impression
très forte que les autres gens partagent
toutes ses impressions
eux aussi sont des esprits dans des
corps libre face à la réalité
on pourrait appeler ça l'expérience
primitif de la vie ou l'intuition nay
c'est ce qui s'impose à nous et oriente
dès le début notre manière de vivre
ensuite on pourrait noter ceci des
valeurs oriente notre existence pour
dire autrement on a des préférences
il ya des choses qu'on aime et des
choses qu'on n'aime pas parfois on a
l'impression de pouvoir expliquer
parfois non parfois c'est évident
parfois non on valorise plus ou moins
certains éléments notre expérience de
l'existence
on décrète qu'il ya du bon et qu'il ya
du mauvais on a même le sentiment qu'il
ya du bien et du mal certaines choses
nous sommes moralement inacceptable sans
qu'on puisse imaginer en doutez donc on
a l'intuition que les valeurs existe
dans la réalité
indépendamment de nous enfin dernier
point a rappelé avant de commencer nous
avons l'intuition d'une dichotomie
fondamentale entre le vrai et le faux
on sent bien que certains trucs qui
paraît devrait sont en fait faut que des
choses qu'on croit bonnes sont peut-être
mauvaise ce qui fonde cette distinction
n'est pas clair dans notre esprit
mais la distinction l'est quelque chose
de vrai n'est pas quelque chose de faux
et ça nous paraît important de ne pas se
tromper si on fait une petite
introspection on a l'impression que ce
qui définit le vrai c'est sa
correspondance avec la réalité
par exemple si on découvre qu'on se
trompait sur quelque chose on peut
formuler sa ainsi je croyais que c'était
bon mais en réalité c'était mauvais où
je croyais qu'il y avait un éléphant
rose devant moi mais en réalité c'est un
reflet en fait tout ceci s'est introduit
la conscience de l'erreur on peut se
tromper
aussi les points 1 2 et 3 sont liés on
associe une valeur à la vérité et à
l'erreur
la vérité dépend de la réalité et on
pense il vaut mieux ne pas se tromper
sur la réalité
mais le problème c'est que définir
précisément tous que recoupe
l'expression se tromper c'est pas simple
et que définir précisément ce qu'il vaut
mieux faire ou ne pas faire c'est pas
beaucoup plus facile puis définir la
réalité c'est pas évident non plus en
tout cas ça suppose que j'ai des
attentes à la fois au sens où je
m'attends à ce que telle ou telle chose
arrive et aussi au sens où je compte sur
quelque chose où je prends certaines
choses pour acquises ou j'ai des
exigences j'insiste sur le double sens
parce que l'un paraît tout à fait neutre
je m'attends à ce que le soleil se lève
demain matin tandis que l'autre
introduit quelque chose de l'ordre du
désir ça m'arrange de penser que le
soleil va se lever demain
ça me permet de vivre une journée
normale et ne veut pas sombrer dans une
crise de panique et je dis ça parce
qu'il est possible d'interroger cette
idée pourquoi vaut-il mieux ne pas se
tromper on pourrait être tenté de dire
parce que ça arrive à survivre
par exemple si on veut rester en vie il
vaut mieux ne pas se planter des
champions mais aujourd'hui les moments
où les erreurs de jugement met
directement en cause la survie de
l'individu
en coûtera alors pourquoi vaut-il mieux
avoir des croyances vrai j'ai peur qu'on
ne se pose pas assez souvent cette
question quel rôle joue la croyance dans
nos vies dans les objectifs ou plus
largement
quelle est la valeur de la vérité cette
question est vertigineuse je le
reconnais mais en même temps ce vertige
indique son importance
pourquoi faire comme si ça allait de soi
pourquoi ceux qui se revendiquent de
l'esprit critique facile beaucoup plus
de temps à déconstruire les croyances
des autres cas clarifie le rapport
qu'ils ont la notion de vérité
après tout des gens très sérieux donnent
une fonction différente à la vérité on
peut débattre de ce qu'est la vérité ou
de la question de savoir si elle doit
être un objectif
alors je trouve un peu gonflé que
certains chevaliers de l'esprit critique
face comme si ça ne posait pas de
problème particulier
comme si on visait évidemment tous la
même chose la discussion entre pascal
angèle et richard lanthier on revient
d'ailleurs qu'on peut s'opposer
radicalement sentent méprisés pour
autant on a trop souvent tendance à
partir dans une enquête critique des
croyances en supposant que notre base
est suffisamment solide pour soutenir
cette investigation par là même qu'on ne
sait pas vraiment confrontés aux
questions fondamentales relatives à la
signification d'un énoncé ou de ses
conditions de vérité bref quel est le
danger
l'erreur le faut la tromperie de
mensonges contre quoi ce bâton il est
bien naïve de brandir la quête de vérité
comme réponse universelle la gravité de
l'erreur du faux du mensonge dépend du
contexte et par conséquent le caractère
salvateur de la vérité aussi ne pas
préciser contre quel type de danger on
se bat c'est faire de ce combat une
valeur absolue c'est un peu dogmatique
on va y revenir dans les autres vidéos
de la série toujours est il que la
possibilité de se tromper introduit un
truc mégane important qu'on verra plus
précisément plus tard le couple croyant
doute disons ceci pour le moment la
possibilité de se tromper introduit le
verbe croire à la place de savoir si je
ne peux pas me tromper je sais si je
peux me tromper je crois attention on
peut défendre l'idée qu'il n'y a rien
donc on ne puisse être absolument
certain disons qu'ils si par impossible
que je me trompe
j'entends les choses dont on ne pourrait
pas imaginer pouvoir être davantage
certains j'aurais donc tendance à dire
que je sais que ma belle pole
même s'il existe une chance non nul que
ce soit faux pour ce qui est de croire
on sent immédiatement qu'il peut y avoir
des 2des de croyance par exemple je
crois très fortement au réchauffement
climatique
je crois fortement que le capitalisme
est un problème pour l'humanité
je crois que michael jordan n'est pas le
plus grand basketteur de tous les
on peut donc douter différemment en
fonction des choses du coup les gens ne
font pas tous la même place au doute
dans leur vie un extrême l'iap iront ils
doutaient tout à tel point qu'on dit que
ses disciples devait le pousser quand il
marchait vers un arbre pour éviter qu'il
se cogne parce qu'il doutait de
l'existence de l'arbre on dit aussi
qu'un de ses disciples s'est noyé devant
lui mais qu'il a laissées mourir parce
qu'il doutait de l'entendre appeler à
l'aide et puis de l'autre côté il ya
jacques attali qui ne doute de rien bon
je présente
quoique mais vous imaginez son souci des
gens qui semblent avoir une grande
confiance dans l'ensemble de leurs
croyances
ce degré de confiance est très important
si on se réfère à la règle d'or si mes
croyances détermine les actions alors le
degré de confiance que j'ai dans mes
croyances détermineront degré
d'implication dans mes actions
pensez simplement à notre comportement
en général on est beaucoup plus
hésitants et précautionneux avec des
inconnus parce qu'on n'est pas sûr de la
manière dont ils vont réagir avec des
proches dont on peut prévoir les
réactions on agit différemment plus
franchement ça renvoie à ce qu'on dit à
deux minutes croire quelque chose c'est
avoir des attentes et précision tout de
suite des attentes relativement au fait
que quelque chose se passe et que
quelque chose ne se passe pas par
exemple croire au père noël c'est
s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait des cadeaux
au pied de l'arbre le 21 décembre mais
pas seulement c'est aussi s'attendre à
ce que s'ils ont passé la nuit devant la
cheminée on va en sortir un peu d'hommes
habillés en rouge venus déposer des
cadeaux et si aussi s'attendre à ce que
les cadeaux ne soit pas placée sous le
sapin par un adulte de la famille pour
prendre un exemple un tout petit peu
plus sérieux croire la gravité c'est
s'attendre à ce qu'un objet tombe si je
lâche et aussi s'attendre à ce que toute
autre chose que sa chute ne se produise
pas c'est ce qu'on avait évoqué dans la
vidéo sur la compréhension avec
l'histoire du prof de physique et de la
plaque de métal croire à la conduction
thermique c'est s'attendre à un certain
phénomène et s'attendre à ce que le
phénomène inverse ne se produise pas
ces exemples sont très simples mais il
faut remarquer quelque chose
immédiatement une croyance qui n'est
attaché à aucune attente est une
croyance très fragile en fait c'est même
une croyance irrationnelle ou une
contradiction un sens très précis parce
que s'y croire en x ne détermine en rien
mon expérience du monde alors cela
équivaut au fait de croire non x6 croire
que l'eau mouiller ne suppose pas de
s'attendre à ce que mes vêtements soient
trempé si je prends une douche tout
habillé
alors la croyance que le mouiller
évident l ebit parce qu elle ne décrit
rien
elle dit la même chose que l'aude
mouille pas ça vaut pour tout un tas de
trucs croire qu'un ami est gentil c'est
par exemple s'attendre à ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas me blesser volontairement
psy croire en la gentillesse de
quelqu'un m'empêche pas de s'attendre à
ce qu'il soit volontairement blessant
cette croyance est vide de sens
parfois on n'a pas les moyens de
vérifier en tout cas immédiatement
croire que le capitalisme est un
problème pour l'humanité
si en tout cas s'attendre à ce qu'il
existe un modèle économique davantage
favorable pour l'humanité et donc le
degré de croyance implique de cas
d'atteintes plus je crois avec certitude
plus je m'attends à ce que quelque chose
se produise et où ne se produise pas au
moins je suis certain - j'ai d'attentes
dans un sens comme dans l'autre
je suis un décide par exemple si je
prends une carte au hasard on va passer
d'une dizaine de cartes
je ne m'attends pas à ce qu'elle soit
une couleur en particulier en revanche
si ça fait sept fois de suite que je
tire un pic
je vais commencer à croire qu'il n'ya
que des pics dans ce paquet de cartes et
m'attendre de plus en plus parce que la
prochaine soit pique aussi bien sûr pour
ce qui est des croyances relatives aux
valeurs à ce qui est bon et mauvais de
nouveaux problèmes surgissent et c'est
ce qu'on va voir dans la seconde vidéo
alors allé la voir
salut